george hearts gave me a demo of the
comma two on a right back to the comma
ai offices in san diego
then we took a quick tour of the office
i found both the comma two system and
the
entire comma ai team and operation
very impressive plus i got a 3d printer
named after me
as one robot to another we're in this
together my brother
and now on to the ride and tour with
george
haws i'm here with uh
driving with george odds and uh
looking at the comma two trying to find
a stretch of road where
we can enable it yeah just start looping
back to the office
i mean i could enable it here but this
isn't really where it shines
but yeah so we don't have we don't have
red lights and stop signs yet
um i don't want to ship it until we have
a real uh
holistic one until we have an end to n1
so you would be able to then like stop
at a stop sign so the longitudinal
control
yeah did you just enable it i just
enabled it yeah so this is the uh so
we're gonna have to stop at this light
but um
how do you enable it uh cruise control
so that's the integrated knobs on the on
the car
yeah we have a good
we'll go on the a bit and that's that's
that's a good test
of uh whether your level two system is
any good
that's pretty intense super crews
actually can't do it um super crews
can't do it because they're they're not
good enough with roll on the road uh
autopilot can do it and we can do it
how is san diego in terms of quality of
roads and lane markings and all that
kind of stuff
pretty mediocre like the rest of
california what's your favorite
uh reason for using comma
like when when do you find the most joy
oh oh it's it's long trips
it's um you know you driving from here
to la you'll do it without a
disengagement
almost you can you can you know it's two
hours to la from here
you can just go to la uh
get in your car and you just sit there
and watch and it's it's a great time
all right so we can we can engage here
so you know watch
so it doesn't technically require
perfect lane marking no not at all
in fact you can do lane changes on roads
that don't have lane markings because
it's
all end to end so i have to get over
three lanes i'm just going to take
control here to do it
especially since there's a cop there so
let me just get
over three lanes and then
this road's a decent demo
yeah so i think only us and autopilot
can do this road
pretty curvy yeah and it's not just
curvy it's also
banked
um and if you don't yeah if you don't do
that well if you don't have a model that
can detect that
um so the longitudinal policy is
actually just being done by the car um
hyundai has quite a competent acc
probably the best one uh so we haven't
really felt the urge to move to our gas
and brakes
there's a few cute things where which
ours will do better and more
holistically than theirs
but um really it's about the turning how
hard is it to get it to be this smooth
uh hard
[Music]
five years of engineering all this end
to end huh
well we are detecting the lane lines
they're used but they're more used as uh
see like right there that's the stock
system being too harsh on the brakes
if you're human driving you would have
been much more gradual on the brakes
then
but we're really going to push to switch
all the longitudinals to open pilot once
we have antenna longitudinal in the same
way we have n10 lateral
[Music]
what's harder and then longitudinal
antenna lateral
we put a lot more work into enter and
lateral because there's a lot more
subtlety in that
the car companies have managed to build
competent longitudinal we have competent
longitudinal using old school policies
but lateral there's so much subtlety for
example like when a lane
splits out should you follow that split
should you stay in the center or should
you stay to one side or
so much subtlety there
[Music]
um and making it all smooth and not
freaked out
yeah and this thing you know the reason
i feel very confident keeping my hands
off the wheel
our torque limit is so much lower than
teslas
so you can't can't do anything crazy we
do injection tests
where one person sits in that seat with
a joystick and the other person keeps
their hands off the wheel
and that person you can't look at them
they're free to jam the joystick in any
direction
and if you don't feel you know safe in
that maneuver but take back over here
because we're getting off here
but um yeah that stretcher road is a is
a
is a competent demonstration of a pilot
yeah that was impressive
it's not the high end um maybe when we
get to the the city streets all engaged
on the city streets
is uh city streets like a compelling use
case
or is that just kind of uh without
intuition builder without
end to end longitudinal it's pretty uh
like it's not really useful as a product
um so it's more just it's cool that it
can do it
and like we don't gate it off but most
of open pilot
uh is highways like most of the value
real game
is highways
but also not just highways also like um
like
one lane each way kind of things like
double yellow kind of roads yeah i was
doing all like the mountains up in
colorado with this thing and just yeah
you get to look at the mountains before
it dries
um so like i can engage it here
yes um now remember the longitudinal
policy is hyundai
uh and it's not ideal for cities
but um so again we're gonna go through
this intersection with no
lines yeah
see notice how there's no line there yet
our placement is still almost human
ideal
yeah this is great so there i mean there
you see we did a stretch of
you know a minute of city and perfectly
human nothing sketchy
so places like that where disengage on
gas is really nice
[Music]
really easy to you know hand off you
always know when that handoff is
happening with the noise
it didn't like keep the acc on or
anything god if it kept the acc on and i
make the turn and it's like
trying to accelerate at a weird time you
know
just asking to have a bad time
i like the the sounds the visual it's
like clear
when it's on and when it's off i love it
well done look at that
damn that's impressive
that's really impressive let's do
intersections without thinking about it
okay that was awesome
it's communicating the uncertainty with
this movement a little bit
yeah i like it humans actually wobble a
little more than you think too
you notice it a lot more than that yeah
that's an interesting point yeah
yeah true
all right i think dude just levinson
mentioned this one of his interviews
he's like so you know we have all these
we have the
safety driver sit in the car and mark
every tiny mistakes it made
and then we also had the safety driver
sit in the car that was being human
driven and mark all the little tiny
mistakes it made
so is the kama office in downtown our
office is right
here we're at uh
kamehameha offices with uh mr george
hearts
can you give us a little tour it doesn't
light up anymore i don't know why
i think most of these dashboards are
okay we're almost
at 30 million open pilot miles
wow um it's a hell of a number
so here here's daley's weeklies and uh
it's actually yeah dailies are like
maybe not two thousand one point five
these are so those are used daily and
then used weekly
yeah that's really cool weeklies are
almost 2.5 and monthly is a little over
three this is how many devices are
on our bot net in the last hour
um bought it last day bought that last
week
is this all over the united states this
is no this is everywhere
uh so here's here's the maps uh here's
the map of the world
uh so wherever we're in the world
so let's see in the last 30 days we had
200 in the u.s and then
korea canada taiwan
and japan's up there
this is our percent engaged so percent
of miles engaged about 50
percent time engaged is about 30. our
disengagements are split pretty evenly
between cancel gas and break
most of our segments are now coming from
comma twos comma twos
comma two is the big the big breakout
for this company yeah
oh yeah that is profitable this is our
live link to the europe office income as
a multinational corporation
george just erased a bunch of top secret
things
censorship the sensors came in yeah look
the missions at the top of the board
solve self-driving cars while delivering
shippable
intermediaries amen
what do we do badly what can we do
better all right good questions
open pilot 1.0 when is that coming up
when those things are done by torch
oh yeah i like how that's a bullet point
that's like move everything to pytorch
yeah oh sorry it's not a data center
it's a compute cluster
legal reasons it's a compute cluster
it's a compute cluster okay
let's sound sex here too data ingestion
multi-training cool
so this is like uh this is the list of
vision board
for open file 1.0 it's not going to
happen for a while
but we the comma 2 is going to get open
pilot 1.0 that's like what i've said
with with the hardware so this is all
going to come to the comma 2
just with otas ota over there
yeah i mean we're getting close on a lot
of these
i'm going to start lowering the real
touch timeout alex jonah this is alex
she's our cll ceo
uh she runs the back their stuff
what's the technical description of the
back there stuff you want to see
yeah i think it's more exciting
um nick do you have any secrets out
i'll blur it out i'll i'll blur
the top
stress test this is our final test the
comma twos hang out here for about 24
hours
we test their heat the temperature
they're light sensors we do cosmetic
checks
um screen checks so
cool pretty exciting you can see they
all start over there
as phones when they get retrofit
but you can see we have a class of
100 phones out right now they're getting
tested
it's kind
machine learning team uh that's chris
also known as virtually chris he's a
famous youtuber
oh wow how did fame change you
i introduced you as a famous youtuber
yes i was the open pilot youtuber
what's what's all the what's that stage
of the
of the assembly
the retrofit phones get bored put on
them
solder to them they get the heat sink in
the fan and then you put the cases on
them
awesome
yeah they're taking case off screens off
here
they're testing streams over here oven
um yeah 3d printer you want to show that
well i'm afraid to take in there it's
very hot and loud well it's all
it's also the home of the compute
cluster
it's not a data center it's not a data
center that's right it's a compute
cluster
prepare yourself
it's the sound of productivity
yeah i like how they have names
meg why
what's the purpose of the rings they
used to be for athletic activity
but now we have too many printers you
can't can't anymore
we just got about 20 printers in the
last few months
they've come from all over the world
literally
poland germany peru how long has it been
how long does it take to uh to
working right now but i promise 49 will
work that would be next number first
i appreciate that that would mean a lot
to me
yeah this is cool
so unfortunately because we got to keep
the bugs and dust out they're covered
but
one you already forgot
the compute cluster so these are these
are our
cpu machines we have three racks that
look like that
um two petabytes of spinning disks
um we're 3080s our 3080s are in
only desktop computers for non-business
purposes
these are gpu machines
what's in there uh v100s
21st century farm we gotta hire a good
farmville player they come farmers
every day um these are the ones that are
ready to ship
wow yeah i think this is these are all
of our growing harness these are all the
carpet support
developers
you know all these are assembled by hand
yeah
that's cool that's amazing that's legit
this is awesome yeah i don't know and
that's that's
that's the office have you been for a
ride among the cars yeah he took me for
a ride it was
it was awesome it was really surprising
how well it worked would you take them
on the highway
it was like the 163 in the city a little
bit too
it uh held up that definitely
not so many secrets though it means like
keep on driving you know
well that's why we replaced it with a
heart we're all big elon fans
you know we elon's success elon's
success is our success
accurate if ios succeeds android
succeeds
you